[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de sens public
vous le savez la promesse est dans le
titre de l'émission donnée du sens à
l'actualité se mettre au service du
public vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des crises que nous
traversons et justement ce soir on va
tenter dans savoir plus sur la
contre-offensive ukrainienne déclenchée
la semaine dernière la résistance russe
est-elle plus forte que prévue la zone
inondée du barrage de carougeka
complique-t-elle la stratégie de volody
mirzelenski les alliés de l'OTAN
peuvent-ils accélérer la livraison
d'armes supplémentaires et notamment de
moyens aériens réponse de nos experts
dans une minute et puis l'autre crise
dont nous parlerons ce soir c'est la
pénurie d'eau la sécheresse qui frappe
notre pays pour la seconde année
consécutive 35 départements ont déjà
pris des arrêtés de restriction et des
sanctions pourraient tomber
on va rentrer en phase de contrôle dur
tous les manquements seront sanctionnés
avec des poursuites devant le tribunal
de police puisque en matière d'eau les
infractions sont des contraventions de
cinquième classe il repunis par une
peine de 1500 euros d'amende comment
mieux partager l'eau faut-il revoir en
profondeur notre façon de produire de
cultiver de consommer et même de
profiter de l'été on en débat dans 45
minutes mais d'abord ce que l'on sait de
la contre-offensive des soldats
Ukrainiens redam ravi de tente d'y voir
clair dans le brouillard de la guerre
informationnelle
des bâtiments ruines des dommages
conséquents de cramatorze à Odessa ces
derniers jours les mêmes images des
dégâts importants côté Ukrainiens après
des frappes russes constat d'impuissance
chez les habitants je veux profiter de
l’air frais de la mer pendant ma
vieillesse mais les ruches ne nous
laissent pas respirer il ne nous laisse
pas vivre et respirer la
contre-offensive ukrainienne est pour
l'instant difficile à percevoir côté
Kremlin on expose l'échec de l'ennemi
images à l'appui
les forces aérospatiales russes sont
menées des frappes massives sur des
lieux où sont concentrés les réserves
opérationnelles des forces armées
ukrainiennes tous les objets assignés
ont été touchés l'objectif a été atteint
les Alliés progrès pourtant la méthode
Coué à l'image du secrétaire général de
l'OTAN
nous ne savons pas si cela marquera un
tournant dans la guerre
progresse et libère de plus en plus de
terrain
plusieurs analystes militaires affirment
que l'Ukraine n'a pas encore lancé le
gros de ses forces dans sa
contre-offensive faisant pour l'instant
du repérage
je présente tout de suite mes invités
Sylvie Berman bonsoir bienvenue ancienne
ambassadrice de France en Chine et en
Russie auteur de Madame l'ambassadeur
publiée aux éditions au Talandier Jérôme
CLAE bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi enseignants prospective et
stratégie à Sciences Po Paris et votre
livre la prospective stratégique est
parue aux éditions Herman à la lazareva
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
correspondante en France de
l'hebdomadaire
Ukraine ski tisden j'accueille également
Laetitia cruppa éditoris politique
bonsoir Laetitia Sylvie Berman qu'est-ce
que vous retenez de cette première
semaine de contre-offensive je parlais
de brouillard de guerre dans les
peut-être dans les mots dans les
attitudes des deux présidents de volody
Muriel skin à côté de Vladimir Poutine
de l'autre on reste pardon on reste
clairement dans la propagande d'un côté
comme de l'autre et il est très
difficile d'apprécier la réalité des
choses donc du côté russe on a montré
des chars Bradley qui avait été détruits
des léopards c'est tout à fait possible
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
le secrétaire général de l'OTAN dit
qu'il faut fournir de plus en plus de
munitions d'armes de chars à l'Ukraine
du côté
ukrainien au contraire on montre le les
drapeaux qui ont été posés sur un
certain nombre de localités qui ont été
reconquises ce qui correspond bon
certainement à une réalité mais pour le
moment on ne sait rien véritablement de
ce qui se passe sur le front les Russes
se sont préparés à une offensive donc
ils se sont installés sur l'ensemble de
la ligne de front et même s'il
commettent un certain nombre d'erreurs
ils se sont préparés à cette
contre-offensive qui d'ailleurs était
retardée le plus possible par les
Ukrainiens pour être sinon sûr de la
gagner mais en tout cas de ne pas la
perdre
Jérôme claires on a souvent dit c'est un
fusil à un coup j'ai entendu ça sur ce
plateau
sauf que c'est un c'est un tir de longue
durée quoi c'est ça qu'il faut peut-être
comprendre c'est que dans cette contre
offensive il y aura sans doute plusieurs
phases et tout dépend si on a une
stratégie et qu'on adapte les moyens la
stratégie ou si on adopte la stratégie
au moyen dont on dispose c'est l'un ou
c'est l'autre en l'occurrence il y a
deux visions une vision sans doute
optimiste qui est de dire et bien
la contre-offensive les actions de
contre-offensif pour reprendre en fait
le terme de vos légers qui lui-même qui
finalement sont disséminés sur tout le
long de la ligne de front du sud au nord
et qui concerne essentiellement les sons
de côté l'image des chars qui n'est pas
révélatrice en fait concerne
essentiellement des duels d'artillerie
des duels de drone en fait c'est de là
c'est de ça dont il s'agit
essentiellement et bien ce serait un
moyen de tester les défenses russes pour
savoir en fonction des faiblesses qui
auraient ou concentré les forces et
c'est là où j'en viens au terme de ce
fusil à un coup parce que la stratégie
militaire jusqu'alors commande plutôt
une contre-offensive pour la partie terr
uniquement unitaire concentré massive en
un point en deux points s'il y a une
opération déception de fixation à un
flanc pour attaquer plus massivement sur
l'autre mais sûrement pas de disséminer
l'accord voilà donc ça veut dire que on
cherche la faille
on cherche la faille et la vision
pessimiste ce serait ben on adapte notre
stratégie au moyen dont on dispose comme
on n'a pas les moyens ou on n'aurait pas
les moyens de cette contre-offensive
massive et unitaire et bien on fait ce
que l'on peut avec ce que l'on a en
espérant que ça puisse consister une
résistance suffisante et ça met un petit
peu en perspective les propos du du
secrétaire général de l'OTAN qui
effectivement
exhorte
l'aide internationale l'aide des alliés
pour avoir plus de munitions j'ajoute
que les points qui sont frappés et ce
qui est détruit de part et d'autre c'est
essentiellement des centres de
commandement essentiellement des dépôts
de munitions et essentiellement des
centres logistiques voilà donc qui
exhorte à plus d'armement pour pouvoir
justement certainement
tous les territoires qu'ils essayent de
garder donc c'est comme ça que c'est
extrêmement difficile d'avancer parce
qu'il y en a vraiment partout partout et
de toutes sortes donc c'est une
difficulté qui est mentionnée
régulièrement
voilà on ne parle aussi de mobilisation
des de la société civile qui aide
l'armée donc non c'est le sujet ne me
rend parce que notre activité
assez inédit finalement dans notre
histoire que cette guerre ne soit
presque pas documentée c'est-à-dire
qu'après quels seront les images qui
vont rester vous parler de propagande
contre propagande mais est-ce qu'on aura
des images sur lesquelles s'appuyer pour
comprendre et documenter encore une fois
cette guerre
je pense que c'est assez difficile parce
que en fait du côté russe comme du côté
ukrainien ce sont des gens en service
commandés qui prennent les images et
quand ce sont des correspondants
étrangers c'est parce que c'est ce qu'on
a voulu leur montrer donc je ne sais pas
ce que ce qu'il y aura à l'avenir pour
pour les historiens sûrement davantage
de choses et y compris d'ailleurs sur
les raisons du déclenchement de de cette
guerre mais pour le moment évidemment
c'est trop tôt parce que c'est
l'histoire et la guerre en direct mais
en même temps je dirais que c'est la
guerre peut-être la plus documentée
quand même peut-être pas assez mais la
plus parce que chaque soldat est la
seule vidéo son téléphone et chaque
civil qui est agressé là aussi voilà
impossibilité de
communiquera sans doute plus tard pour
l'instant on ne les voit pas toutes ces
images mais elle sortiront sans doute
plus tard vous parliez du minage vous
propose une première déclaration un
premier témoignage dans ce dans ce débat
réaction de la vis ministre ukrainienne
de la défense elle parle de 7 C contre
offensive chose
en ce qui concerne le sud comme vous le
savez une offensive est en cours dans
plusieurs directions
progressive mais certaine des forces
armées et dans le même temps l'ennemi
oppose une forte résistance à tams
brownies
de l'Ukraine sont confrontés au minage
total des champs à l'utilisation de
drone kamikaze à des bombardements
intenses l'ennemi n'abandonne pas
facilement ses positions
est-ce que c'est plus difficile
d'attaquer que de défendre naturellement
d'ailleurs bon alors on peut discuter
des chiffres mais non dans toutes les
bonnes écoles de guerre en général on
dit que le rapport de force qu'il faut
alors à bord de force sur les trous pas
sur les blindés sur les chars c'est
composites tout ça mais en gros c'est de
trois contraints trois quatre
contraintes quasiment trois contre un
c'est le rapport de force qu'il faut
pour
prendre une place et la maintenir donc
pour l'instant l'Ukraine ne l'a pas ce
naturellement et non seulement il l'a
pas mais c'est même effectivement plutôt
inversé en dépit de des difficultés
qu'on a à estimer ce que peut avoir la
Russie et l'idée qu'on peut avoir de ce
qu'a lucrènes si on prend les 12
brigades de 3 4000 hommes dont dispose
potentiellement l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
c'est 2 à 3 d'engager ça fait à peu près
50 000 hommes la Russie entre l'ordre de
batailles constitué les pertes qui a pu
avoir et la mobilisation dont on estime
qu'elle a plutôt pas mal réussi en
mobilisant les zones rurales plutôt que
les zones urbaines de la Russie on est
sur ce rapport ce rapport de force et
sans doute au-delà donc si vous voulez
dans une logique pour la Russie où il
s'agit plutôt de faire une défense
d'attrition avec des frappes dans la
profondeur c'est à dire c'est beaucoup
plus facile surtout quand on a théorisé
et intégré le fait de perdre des hommes
ce qui est le cas de la Russie de
défendre donc ce sera très difficile
pour la l'Ukraine de percer cette ligne
de défense faite de dandagerons faites
de champs de mine faites de trancher
aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment qui protège voilà les drones
plus l'aviation de chasse on l'oublie
mais du côté russe il y a quand même eu
une inflexion sur ce plan-là et il y a
quand même des frappes au niveau même de
la ligne de contact et pas uniquement
dans la profondeur de la part de
l'aviation donc pour arriver à
l'aviation russe de l'aviation russe
d'accord pour arriver à percer ou est-ce
que l'aviation ukrainienne pour le coup
et est au sol inexistante donc pour
percer cette ligne là qui est
aujourd'hui allez disons ébréché à
certains endroits sur la partie
centrestre il y a vraiment trois zones
le sud statu quo le Nord statu quo le
sud c'est un peu disputé il y a des
avancées possibles mais au conditionnel
on y reviendra et au centre un léger
remodelage du front à la faveur aussi
des quelques villages qui ont été repris
sur les flancs sud de darkmouth et flan
nord de barkout voilà bon mais si vous
voulez rien n'a été véritablement percé
donc cette ligne de défense là elle
reste quasiment intacte aujourd'hui un
mot aussi des conditions
météorologiques à la réserve parce que
volody marzeninski on a parlé il a dit
que la pluie je vais le citer les pluies
rendre notre tâche plus difficile oui
bien sûr parce que ça empêche l'avancée
des véhicules militaires et ça non
mettre de l'eau dans les tranchées donc
évidemment que ça complique les choses
mais aussi oublions pas la tragédie que
c'est passé le 6 juin donc le barrage
qui est qui était explosé on y reviendra
un peu plus tard sur le barrage si vous
voulez bien parce que je voudrais qu'on
entende une autre réaction cette fois-ci
de Vladimir Poutine pour voir un peu
comment vous percevez ces prises de de
parole une déclaration du prénom russe
qui date de Mardi et elle est
intéressante parce que il reconnaît
manqué de certains armements écoutons
apparu que plusieurs choses nous
manquaient des munitions de haute
précision les équipements de
communication des drones nous en avons
mais pas en quantité suffisante
malheureusement
assez rare d'entendre alors j'allais
dire mais à cool pas assez certainement
exagéré mais d'entendre ce type de
propos de la part de Blagnac est-ce que
ça s'explique je vais peut-être
complètement à côté de la plaque mais
est-ce que ça s'explique par la pression
que gaugine le chef des milices Wagner
mais en permanence sur le manque d'armes
etc est-ce que est-ce qu'il répond un
peu à ça ou pas d'ailleurs alors un
frigorne mais aussi ceux qu'on appelle
les 1000 blogueurs qui sont des
blogueurs donc
militaires et qui sont
ultra-nationalistes et qui qui pousse
quasiment à l'extermination des des
Ukrainiens mais en fait c'est pas la
première fois qu'il reconnaît une erreur
de ce type est-ce qu'il avait déjà
reconnu une erreur dans la mobilisation
parce que la première mobilisation
certains
étudiants alors qu'il avait indiqué que
il n'en ferait pas partie avait reçu un
convocation une convocation et donc il
avait reconnu des problèmes logistiques
il a reconnu des problèmes logistiques
dans l'armée donc en fait c'est pas tout
à fait là la première fois qu'il le fait
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il est formé
content de son de son ministre de la
Défense il le fait savoir
est-ce que c'est aussi clair que ça
alors on a fait tout un débat sur Wagner
hier
que ça constituerait
je ne suis pas tout à fait en ligne avec
le fait que ce serait un aveu de
faiblesse pour moi parce que on sent
quand même une certaine sérénité une
certaine confiance dans la façon
d'annoncer ça est-ce que c'est pas je
vais poser des questions une façon
d'enjamber un peu la contrefensive sur
le mode on est déjà dans le retour
d'expérience déjà dans le bilan pour
s'améliorer pour la suite ça ça peut
être une lecture la deuxième lecture qui
est plus à destination des autorités
américaines européennes des états majors
qui est plus stratégiques puisqu'il a
dit que la contre-offensive ukrainienne
n'avait pas de façon assez sobre sans en
faire trop n’avait pas atteint ses
objectifs est-ce que c'est pas aussi un
moyen de pointer ce qui est
véritablement critique
sur les frappes actuellement qui ont
lieu sur toute la ligne de front dont je
vous disais que c'était des duels
d'artillerie et de drones et aussi de
frappes aériennes s'agissant de la
Russie de haute précision ou de moins
haute précision avec des bombes guidées
sur la ligne de contact et c'est une
façon de dire certes nous en manquons
mais en creux l'Ukraine n'en a pas du
tout voilà et donc cette
contre-offensive qui se mène à partir de
ces frappes là pour l'instant la partie
blindée char est existante mais encore
secondaire et encore une fois je vous le
disais n'est pas on n'a pas encore percé
lignes de France que au passage écarte
l'idée selon laquelle plus de 30%
auraient pu être auraient pu être
supprimé ça pour le coup c'est de la
propagande russe totale voilà ce serait
contradictoire mais c'est un moyen de
vraiment mettre le focus sur les
capacités critiques dans cette
contre-offensive et de dire l'Ukraine
n'en a pas et donc l'Ukraine ne peut pas
faire but là-dessus et sur le dans les
premiers jours de cette contre-offensive
j'ai entendu parler d'une
supériorité ukrainienne dans les combats
de nuit grâce à des appareils de viser
nocturnes plus sophistiquées est-ce que
ça sort d'où ça la lazareva est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est ça fait partie de
la voilà de de la propagande ou des
informations qui sont qui sont données
depuis quelques jours je serai pas vous
dire plus très honnêtement parce que
c'est vrai que c'est les informations
qui sort des sources qui sont pas
traitées d'identifiables donc bon j'ai
le comme vous mais peut-être là dessus
oui non hypothèse il est possible
effectivement que ces lunettes de vision
nocturne bon déjà normalement une
attaque ça se fait toujours de nuit on
aime bien si on sait qu'on attaque la
nuit pourquoi on attaque la mi-bas parce
que malgré tout quand même ça rend les
choses plus difficiles pour celui qui
défend voilà si vous avez des lunettes
de vision nocturne c'est pas comme en
plein jour mais effectivement ça aide si
vous n'en avez pas vous êtes vraiment
privé de tout il est possible que les
Russes en ait mais pas en tout point et
en tout point des villages qui ont été
repris là je c'est une hypothèse c'est
aux conditionnelle mais les villages qui
ont été repris c'était quand même pas
des bastions forts c'était pas des zones
désertiques comme on l'entend souvent
dans la la comment la propagande pro
russe mais c'était quand même des zones
très faiblement peuplées au final ça a
été du combat d'infanterie
éventuellement soutenu et appuyé par
l'artillerie et par les chars ou ils ont
été débusqué un inain les les soldats
qui étaient dans les immeubles les
maisons mais qui pour le coup n'étaient
peut-être pas équipé de lunettes de
vision nocturne pas que les Russes n'en
ont pas voilà alors on était au sol on
va maintenant parler de des combats ou
des non-combats aériens et je vous
propose pour commencer d'appeler Tam
traduit qui va nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau pour parler de ces manœuvres de
l'OTAN bonsoir bienvenue c'était en
début de semaine un exercice très
important on peut même dire historique
oui c'est le plus important des
exercices de l'OTAN depuis 1951 250
aéronefs participent depuis lundi à
cette opération baptisée air Defender 23
ils viennent de 25 pays membres et pays
partenaires de l'OTAN dont le Japon et
la Suède qui sont candidat à l'adhésion
objectif assumé de cette opération faire
une démonstration de force on aura
occidentale et en Europe centrale face
aux menaces potentielles de la Russie
l'opération est organisée par
l'Allemagne et cela confirme donc son
rôle croissant au sein de l'alliance
militaire écoutez le chef de l'armée de
l'herbe allemande ingurer
23 nous montrons prouvons et démontrons
la capacité de défense de cette alliance
le signal de cet exercice n'est dirigé
contre personne c'est un signal pour
nous dirigé vers l'intérieur vers l'OTAN
ce sont principalement des pays de
l'OTAN qui participent à cet exercice
coordonné par l'Allemagne pour montrer
que nous sommes capables de défendre ce
pays et cette alliance sofa trading bien
sûr le général Alma beau dire que
l'exercice n'est dirigé contre personne
c'est un message de dissuasion très
clair envoyé à Vladimir Poutine en
pleine guerre en Ukraine alors dans le
détaille en quoi consiste cette
opération
c'est la prévoit que l'Allemagne est en
partie occupée par une alliance
militaire étrangère du coup Berlin
appelle l'OTAN à l'aide sans suivre
bombardement de ville et de porc
déplacement de troupes etc total 10 000
personnes sont mobilisées l'objectif de
tout ça tester la capacité de toutes ces
troupes de toutes ces armées venant de
différents pays à travailler ensemble
c'est tester leur interopérabilité comme
on dit pour un exercice qui va se
dérouler dans l'espace aérien allemand
mais aussi tchèque laiton estonien des
pays qui ont des frontières donc avec la
Russie et plus de la moitié des avions
aussi viennent des États-Unis car l'une
des priorités de cette opération c'est
aussi de tester la réactivité des
Américains en cas d'attaque en Europe
l'idée de cette opération elle est née
en 2018 en partie en réponse à
l'annexion de la Crimée par la Russie
mais aujourd'hui la guerre en Ukraine
lui donne encore plus d'importance et on
l'a évoqué rapidement dans ce débat
au-delà de cette démonstration de force
l'OTAN se mobilise aussi pour soutenir
cette contre-offensive
un mois du sommet de Vilnius les pays de
l'OTAN sont en pleine discussion en
pleine négociation de leur plan d'aide à
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui à Bruxelles les
ministres de la défense de l'Alliance
parle aide militaire et sur ce point Ian
Stoltenberg le secrétaire général de
l'OTAN qu'on a déjà entendu a demandé un
soutien militaire plus important pour
soutenir l'offensive crinienne
le besoin le plus urgent le plus
flagrant et bien sûr de nous assurer que
les Ukrainiens ont les armes les
munitions et les approvisionnements
qu'on continue à mener l'offensive comme
vous le savez il ne s'agit pas de
déployer quelques chars d'assaut ou
quelques systèmes de défense aériens il
s'agit aussi de s'assurer qu'il peut
fonctionner qu'ils ont les munitions le
carburant des pièces de rechange et
qu'ils peuvent être réparés pendant
l'avancée de l'offensive
pour l'OTAN en ce début d’offensive
n'est pas seulement d'être dans la
démonstration de force mais bien de
faire la preuve de son soutien à
l'Ukraine c'est l'un des enjeux de la
réunion qui se tient actuellement à
Bruxelles et l'enjeu de la Réunion se
tiendra également à Vilnus dans un mois
merci beaucoup Tom pour toutes ces
informations civil je voudrais
comprendre parce que cette cote
offensive tout le monde l'attend de
depuis longtemps ce c'est manœuvres
aériennes elles sont prévues elles aussi
depuis longtemps comment vous expliquer
cette déclaration du du secrétaire
général de l'OTAN qui semble découvrir
que l'Ukraine a encore besoin d'un
soutien plus important comment vous
l'analysez je crois pas qu'il
le découvre pas l'Ukraine ne cesse de
demander davantage d'armes je crois le
fait aussi d'avoir montré des
chars qui ont été bon
touché montre qu'il y a besoin
effectivement de remplacer de réparer
d'assurer une certaine maintenance et
évidemment la contre-offensive
ukrainienne est très
importante pour le temps et pour les
occidentaux puisque on la soutient et
que donc un échec serait également en
partie un échec
de cette coalition
occidentale donc il y a deux choses il y
a effectivement
l'exercice aérien qui est assez
traditionnel en fait
la Russie ne va pas attaquer un pays de
l'OTAN même le ministre de la Défense
craénien qui était à Paris il y a
quelques mois la dit très clairement
mais en même temps c'est toujours le
même principe si vise pas comme
Parabellum si tu veux la paix prépare la
guerre donc il y a ce côté effectivement
défensif dissuasif de l'OTAN et puis le
deuxième volet c'est cette aide à
l'offensive ukrainienne et je crois que
c'est dans la même
déclaration qu'il dit aussi que le but
c'est que l'Ukraine soit dans la
meilleure position possible avant de
négocier
de négociation
on écoute de nouveau James soltenberg
qui effectivement se projette regardez
plus les Ukrainiens seront en mesure de
libérer de terre plus auront du poids à
la table des négociations et plus le
président Poutine comprendra qu'il ne
gagnera jamais cette bataille et qu'il
ne gagnera jamais cette guerre
d'agression sur le champ de bataille
on a quand même du mal à imaginer
Vladimir Poutine et autour d'une table
de négociation de paix non pour le
moment il n'en est évidemment pas
question on précisément parce que le but
des Ukrainiens c'est de remporter cette
offensive ou au moins de gagner le plus
de terrains possibles pour être
effectivement en position de force la
question qui se pose un peu dans le
monde entier parce que il y a une
multiplication des plans de paix bon il
y a eu plein de pêche chinois de de
l'Afrique du Sud avec d'autres pays
africains de l'Indonésie en dernier lieu
les Américains réfléchissent aussi à
cela le moment n'est pas venu mais je
crois que dans l'esprit de tout le monde
il y a l'idée qu'on donnera un jour
autour de la de la table de négociation
mais bon l'Ukraine à ce moment là soit
sera en position de décider parce
qu'elle ne pourra pas gagner davantage
ce qui est une possibilité pour le
moment on n'en sait rien bien sûr c'est
et acceptera effectivement les les
pressions mais c'est pas encore une fois
c'est pas le moment c'est encore le
temps de la guerre mais c'est
intéressant que le secrétaire général de
l'OTAN se projette aussi dans cette
phase diplomatique on va parler du
combat aérien mais comment ces
déclarations de de secrétaire général
dont toi elles sont perçues en
Ukraine mais effectivement
essentiellement c'est ce qu'on retient
nous c'est le message de augmentation
d'aide c'est ce qu'il nous faut donc des
larmes parce que on espère avoir
justement des avions comme vous le savez
comme vous l'avez mentionné et c'est ça
ce que ce que retiennent surtout notre
offre attention après pour au sujet de
négociation pour l'instant on ne veut
pas surtout donc les conditions
préalables pour le crâne c'est le retour
aux frontière 91
tant qu'on est loin de ça mais vraiment
très loin de ça et aujourd'hui on est
très loin de ça on ne veut même pas
aborder la question de puissance dans
cette négociation
de son côté donc donc voilà alors sur le
combat aérien
effectivement vous nous l'avez dit très
rapidement tout à l'heure pour l'instant
il y a pas d'avion côté ukrainien que
les choses soient claires quoi parce que
on a on a entendu des annonces de
livraison etc de on en est où de ça
initialement le rapport de force en
termes de sur le plan uniquement aérien
c'était entre l'Ukraine et la Russie de
1 à 9 et je vous ai dit le 1 3 2 alors
donc effectivement la dimension aérienne
est complètement absente de ce conflit
côté ukrainien elle a été réinvesti côté
russe à l'automne 2022 ce qui leur a
permis de reprendre un petit peu forcé
vigueur et elle s'affine depuis quelques
exercices d'entraînement pour des
frappes de haute précision depuis le
printemps cette dimension aérienne en
fait c'est un peu cruel d'ailleurs cet
exercice là le timing de cet exercice
parce que il a été préparé en 2018 il a
été dimensionné structuré pour en
réponse à l'annexion de la Crimée et
précisément il nous dit quoi il nous dit
que pour espérer faire bouger les lignes
et avoir un rapport de force favorable
pour retrouver finalement des
reconquêtes territoriales il faut ça
passe par une campagne aérienne massive
bien structurée sur le modèle otanien de
grande ampleur en préalable à tout autre
chose mais forcément depuis longtemps je
vous ai entendu plusieurs fois sur ce
plateau le dire et donc pourquoi le
pardon moi je pose j'assume des
questions un peu de béotien parfois
pourquoi lancer une contre-offensive si
s'il y a pas ce cette force aérienne
côté ukrainien si elle est quasi enfin
je sais pas je vais pas dire vous à
l'échec mais si ça rampe pessimiste
d'une certaine manière
le monde se constat-là du coup la
question qui se pose c'est quel est
l'état final recherché quels sont les
arrières pensées et je suis en ligne en
totalement avec ce que disait Sylvie
Berkman il y a le temps de la guerre et
puis le temps de la négociation ou il
faudra je reprends vos mots un moment ou
un autre que l'Ukraine accepte un
certain nombre de pressions en fonction
des gains territoriaux qu'elle aura pu
avoir qui ne seront peut-être pas ceux
d'un retour
des gains dans les frontières qui ne
sont pas des frontières mais une un état
de fait de 2014 peut-être encore en deçà
là le curseur sera placé et en fonction
d'un certain nombre de compensations qui
pourront advenir de toutes les parties
prenantes à ce conflit y compris de la
Chine vous l'avez dit naturellement
internationaux de la chiliée des
États-Unis de la Chine de l'Europe dans
une certaine mesure aussi qui aura son
mot à dire et donc
précisément la question maintenant c'est
d'essayer de faire bouger ce curseur
pour permettre le chemin faisant que les
protagonistes 1 et 2 Russie-Ukraine se
mettent à la table parce que soyons
aussi quand même lucides sur le fait que
la Russie aimerait bien que ça s'arrête
quand même oui ça c'est un point qu'il
faut avoir en tête bien sûr c'est à dire
qu'elle serait peut-être aussi prête à
des concessions peut-être je dis ça
comme ça mais là je dis sous le contrôle
d'une diplomate peut-être qu'une
autonomie des régions
occupées serait quelque chose d'audible
voilà ces entre-deux voilà ça peut être
pourquoi pas il y aura des la
diplomaties fraction neuve à ce
moment-là de toute façon la Russie c'est
qu'elle ne peut pas être gagnée
c'est-à-dire obtenir son objectif
initial donc ça c'est déjà perdu pour
elle là j'entends que l'Ukraine va avoir
du mal à gagner sans avion
risque d'avoir du mal effectivement à
reconquérir l'ensemble des territoires
crimes et comprise
donc il faudra voir à un moment
effectivement il y aura une négociation
il y aura des garanties fortes pour
l'Ukraine en particulier en matière de
sécurité et sur ces territoires
au début de la négociation le dimanche
pas de la négociation et de la guerre où
il y avait encore des négociations entre
les deux parties par l'intermédiaire de
la Turquie veut le dire zenenski avait
proposé un gel du statut de la Crimée
pendant 15 ans il l'avait proposé si je
me souviens bien des référendums un sous
supervision international donc ce sont
des choses sur lesquelles on pourra
revenir mais pour le moment c'est normal
que pour l'Ukraine ce soit inacceptable
maintenant parce qu'il y a un espoir
effectivement de gagner cette
contre-offensive et c'est vrai que sur
le plan moral ça peut être perçu que
finalement une prime à l'agresseur mais
en même temps il y a des principes de
réalité dans la vie et la guerre
également est-ce que vous craignez une
sorte de lassitude finalement des alliés
de l'Ukraine qui finissent par la guerre
durant lui mettre une pression politique
pour sortir de ce conflit ben c'est ce
risque existe toujours dès le début mais
on ne pense aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens raisonnables dans le monde entier
et qu'on comprend que le grain ne se bat
pas que pour elle mais aussi pour la
démocratie dans le sens propre c'est pas
la grande pathétisme que je fais c'est
juste le constat justement les réalités
parce que quel sera le monde si la
Russie puisse remporter répartir avec le
territoire conquis même parti c'est le
monde on peut venir dans la maison de
voisins tout détruire vieux de sa femme
entre son enfant partir et est-ce que
vous voulez vivre dans ce monde là je ne
pense pas donc je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ne veulent pas
encourager ce type de comportement la
Russie ce n'est pas la seule dictature
qui est
disons voué à l'expansionnisme il y a
aussi la Chine qui regarde de côté de
Taiwan il y a aussi d'autres pays qui
peuvent s'inspirer de cet exemple et
dire ah bon mais si on peut permettre à
la Russie de envahir le morceau de
l'Ukraine et faire ce qu'on veut dedans
c'est surtout ça c'est surtout les gens
voyez ce qu'on voit ce qu'ils font sur
les territoires occupés c'est peut-être
voilà le réseau l'essentiel pour nous
pour essayer de mettre vraiment tout un
œuvre pour récupérer tous les terres
avec nos gens alors le les diplomates la
diplomatie est toujours à l'oeuvre lundi
à l'Élysée Emmanuel Macron a réactivé le
triangle de vémar pour évoquer
évidemment cette contrefensive
ukrainienne et la coordination militaire
Laetitia va d'abord rappeler ce qu'est
le triangle le Triangle de Weimar moi je
dis allemand non mais on le dit comme on
veut c'est la plateforme qui a été créée
en 1991 pour discuter entre la Pologne
entre l'Allemagne et la France pourquoi
Thomas l'objectif c'est bien sûr
d'essayer que de s'installe pas en
Europe cette fracture Est-Ouest ou
ancien nouveau et donc depuis sa
création il n'a pas été quand même très
actif ce triangle mais là dans l'année
c'est la deuxième fois que Emmanuel
Macron le réunit et à l'ordre du jour
c'était bien sûr la coordination
militaire qui a été discutée lundi mais
on va écouter le président Emmanuel
Macron qui lui a été un tout petit peu
plus loin dans sa prise de parole
officielle il est allé bien sûr sur
cette fameuse table de négociation dont
nous parlons depuis tout à l'heure
évidemment il y a cette contre-offensive
nous la souhaitons la plus victorieuse
possible
pour pouvoir ensuite déclencher une
phase de négociation dans de bonnes
conditions mais notre soutien durera
aussi longtemps
que nécessaire
et c'est un message que le président
français tient quasiment depuis le début
de la guerre bah oui parce qu'il se rêve
en leader européen qui serait le chef
d'orchestre de ces négociations entre
Ukraine et Russie et puis lundi soir il
y a eu un petit caillou dans la
chaussure d'Emmanuel Macron parce que
ensuite c'est le président polonais qui
a pris la parole et lui allez un cran
plus loin on va l'écouter les
Ukrainiens veulent la même chose ils
veulent politiquement rejoindre la
communauté de l'Ouest nous devons leur
permettre cela et c'est l'un des sujets
de notre réunion d'aujourd'hui
pour l'Europe de l'Est cette adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN c'est l'inscrit le
président ukrainien assez dit bien sûr
favorable à appeler la communauté
internationale à plusieurs reprises mais
c'est aussi et c'est surtout la ligne
rouge pour les Russes avec quelle
position
sans être sûr que les États-Unis sont
prêts ou pas à intervenir directement
donc si l'apologue et les pays baltes
poussent la France et l'Allemagne
continue de freiner vraisemblablement il
n'y a aucune avancée avant l'année
prochaine avant le sommet de Washington
pour les 75 ans de l'OTAN intégré
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN ça semble impossible
là en temps de guerre c'est totalement
impossible
et le président polonais parce que les
Polonais ont eu une peur absolue de la
Russie et essaie depuis le début de
d'entraîner le temps dans la guerre donc
on peut effectivement les comprendre
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que ce
n'est pas seulement l'Allemagne ou la
France qui sont opposés à l'entrée dans
le temps mais les Américains aussi parce
que
ça signifierait si on intégré un en
guerre que le temps va envoyer des
hommes sur le terrain donc ça n'a pas et
donc les États-Unis donc même s'il ne le
feraient pas parce qu'en général ils
préfèrent que ce soit les autres qui se
battent mais enfin ils le font du ciel
ou en fournissant des armes
effectivement donc ça n'a pas de sens
aujourd'hui simplement bon personne ne
veut l'exclure je crois qu'il faudra
surtout travailler sur des garanties et
en ce qui concerne l'Union européenne il
y a une différence entre le démarrage
des négociations d'adhésion et
l'adhésion elle-même parce que il y a un
certain nombre de critères de prérequis
je n'en sais rien ça peut prendre
plusieurs années effectivement ce qui a
un problème d'État de droit qui n'est
pas respecté bon pour le moment en
Ukraine il y a un problème de corruption
qui est très élevé on peut pas se
permettre pour l'Union européenne
d'intégrer un pays qui ne respecterait
pas ce qu'on appelle la qui
communautaire mais ça n'empêcherait pas
de démarrer les négociations et
d'accompagner les enclencher processus
effectivement symboliquement dans cette
démarche européenne un mot là-dessus sur
cette perspective on a bien compris
effectivement que c'est impossible à
l'instant T mais est-ce que cette
perspective d'une entrée de l'Ukraine à
l'OTAN et dans l'Union européenne ça
peut être justement parlait de d'une
future table de négociation un levier
quelque chose qui pèse dans le corps
ukrainien alors c'est impossible
effectivement je suis totalement en
ligne avec ce que dit Sylvie berckman
très concrètement si l'Ukraine intégrait
l'OTAN qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on
respecte si on respecte les règles il
faut rentrer l'exercice et redfendeurs
là qui se déroule actuellement en
Allemagne s'appliquerait directement
c'est ça qui se passerait très
concrètement donc on voit bien que là
c'est un logo comme comme on pourrait le
dire à l'inverse est-ce que pour autant
ça signifie qu'on ne peut pas envisager
cette entrée à terme pourquoi pas est-ce
que ça peut constituer un levier de
négociation bien sûr on parlerait des
garanties de sécurité
si sur la question des gains
territoriaux la le manœuvre est quand
même assez limité précisément pour
toutes les raisons de rétablissement
possible de rapports de force qu'on a
déjà dit l'idée d'avoir des garanties de
sécurité ça c'est un levier de
négociation fort vous incluez dans la
sécurité le développement qui est un
pont considérable avec une aide à la
reconstruction massive ça c'est des
choses qui éventuellement les Ukrainiens
peuvent entendre s'agissant des
garanties de sécurité et de
l'intégration de l'OTAN vous pouvez
envisager par exemple un Partenariat
pour la Paix Partenariat pour la paix
c'est une façon d'associer l'Ukraine à
l'OTAN il y a un certain nombre de pays
du Moyen-Orient par exemple qui font
partie du Partenariat pour la Paix de
l'OTAN ça c'est une version douce déjà
et ça veut dire que les règles les
règles d'intervention s'appliquent pas à
ce moment les règles d'intervention pas
mais il y a une coopération malgré tout
douce avec une capacité à éventuellement
opérer ensemble d'interopérabilité la
coalition contre daesh par exemple il y
a un certain nombre de pays du
Moyen-Orient qui opère et précisément
l'interopérabilité a du sens donc il y a
une façon aussi de rapproché toujours
plus d'être capable en capacité d'opérer
ensemble de se soutenir et ça ça
contribue aux garanties de sécurité on
peut adjoindre des aides en armement de
l'Union européenne et ou de l'OTAN etc
etc jusqu'à l'adhésion voilà qui est un
symbole et qui effectivement au-delà du
symbole permet de se couvrir de
l'article 5 mais qui néanmoins qui
néanmoins sans aller jusque là permet un
rapprochement avec l'OTAN je voudrais
qu'on termine de ce débat par un dernier
chapitre consacré aux conséquences de la
destruction du du barrage de Kafka à la
lasariva déjà peut-être quelle est la
situation sur place comment vivent les
Ukrainiens qui sont sinistrés dans dans
cette zone mais très très difficilement
on ne reçoit tout le temps les appels à
l'aide en fait les gens se sont assez
seuls c'est la première fois qu'on a une
catastrophe de tel ampleur à part qu'ils
ont besoin d'aide potable et de plein
d'autres choses il y a un problème
sécuritaire sanitaire qui est immense
parce qu'il fait chaud il y a beaucoup
de cadavres d'animaux qui qui qui
et on sait pas comment le traiter est-ce
qu'il y a une algorithme international
pour les ce type de
catastrophes comment agir rapidement et
efficacement qui peut nous aider on est
aussi assez déçus par la mollesse de la
réaction internationale donc les gens
sont un peu voilà un peu perdus un peu
dans l'idée qu'on est obligé de se
prendre en charge je connais notre
oignon en nous c'est nous et que il y a
que nous qui peuvent la communauté
internationale est pas là quoi c'est le
constat que vous faites c'est le constat
qui est fait majoritairement dans
plusieurs médias et société civile aussi
enfin très à l'oeuvre très efficace
c'est compliqué plus compliqué parce
qu'on est dans un pays en guerre parce
que l'intervention serait perçue enfin
je c'est vrai qu'on l'a pour l'instant
le constat fait à la laserva il est
juste on a laissé les Ukrainiens
quasiment seul face à cette catastrophe
alors je ne connais pas précisément ce
qui a été fait ce que j'ai entendu c'est
le président de la République dire qu'il
allait apporter une aide à l'Ukraine
pour pour cela sous quelle forme j'avoue
que je ne sais pas ça reste ça reste
encore assez embryonnaire on va dire en
tout cas il y a pas un mouvement
international c'est ça que c'est ça que
je veux dire sur le plan militaire
ce qui est intéressant on a quand ce
barrage a été détruit on s'est tout de
suite dit est-ce que c'est une stratégie
russe pour empêcher la contre-offensive
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de ça aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'était un point de passage
qui a été perdu une certaine façon les
faits rien que l'effet à ce stade on ne
peut pas dire que ce sont les Russes qui
ont détruit je sais mais c'est important
de le rappeler malgré tout après
l'activité que ce ne soit pas les Russes
je reste quand même je reste quand même
prudent parce que regardez le cas de
North stream depuis ça a été quand même
largement documenté bon donc restons
vous êtes vous êtes l'expert mais j'ai
du mal à trouver
de l'Ukraine à fait affaire non plus
mais il se peut aussi que ce soit des
suites des premiers chocs qui ont eu
lieu en automne à l'automne dernier
voilà bon une fois qu'on a mis ça de
côté parce que c'est important dans
cette guerre informationnelle de savoir
revenir au fait de ce qui a testé à qui
profite le crime vraisemblablement à la
Russie en effet néanmoins c'est quand
même une ligne de coupure pour les deux
voilà et effectivement ça profite à la
Russie parce que ça neutralise une
partie de la ligne de front et la partie
sud en particulier ce qui lui permet
effectivement de concentrer ses forces
notamment au nord et pourquoi pas à
Belgorod précisément puisque on en parle
plus mais la
globalement la comment l'offensive par
les milices pro enfin russe
pro-ukrainienne ont quand même été ont
quand même été boutés pour l'instant ça
reste quand même contrôlé par les Russes
voilà donc effectivement cette
réarticulation possible au nord du fait
de la neutralisation de la ligne de
France Sud profite au Russe voilà
dernier mot puisque c'est l'une des
informations de cette fin d'après-midi
que nous apprennent au contraire de
l'Agence France Presse quatre pays
Royaume-Uni États-Unis Danemark Pays-Bas
annonce la livraison de centaines de
missiles de défense aérienne
supplémentaires à l'Ukraine c'est une
bonne nouvelle
mais ça peut ça peut changer la donne ça
ça peut pas changer la donne c'est une
suite de fournitures évidemment de
défense de défense solaire défenses et
aérienne de missiles pour l'artillerie
de drone de chars supplémentaires car
s'il y avait un combat terrestre
mobilisant les chars il y aurait
énormément d'attrition pour passer ses
dents de dragons ses champs de mine il y
en a déjà même si j'ai dit que c'était
plutôt second par rapport aux frappes
d'artillerie et de drones il y en a déjà
parce que les champs de mine permettent
de canaliser en fait l'afflux des
blindés et des chats et donc de
précisément d'articuler le dispositif
russe et de frapper et donc pertinent il
y a beaucoup de pertes donc il faudra
davantage de chats il en faudrait sans
doute plusieurs centaines aujourd'hui il
y en a un peu plus d'une centaine donc
c'est une somme de fournitures
d'armement sur toutes les composantes et
sur la composante aérienne qui fait sens
voilà donc c'est une bonne nouvelle
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Sylvie verman je
rappelle le titre de votre livre madame
l'ambassadeur aux éditions
Talandier et puis voilà Jérôme cleche la
prospective stratégique aux éditions
Hermann merci encore et à bientôt sur
public